make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay what's going on guys this is Rob
and we are picking back up with Jonathan
Hickman's x-men now here's the thing is
this kind of funny you guys recall when
we were covering New Mutants and we had
that situation where the starjammers had
just kind of stolen this artifact right
like at the very beginning of the New
Mutants story the starjammers stole this
artifact and left the New Mutants behind
in order to be captured this is one of
those things that Jonathan Hickman does
where he takes a small little thing and
he ties it into a big thing later on
down the line now what's even more
interesting is this will become even
more important later on down the line
especially because we're probably gonna
end up having like some pretty massive
or significant conflict or something
like that keep in mind that it might
take about three years for this whole
thing to flesh out that's about how long
it took for his Avengers and New
Avengers to conclude right a lot of
people forget that a lot of people think
the whole thing was written in like a
year doesn't really work that way it
took quite some time to reach the finish
line when it came to that story but what
we're basically shown here is what's
called the brood and there's the other
the brood race itself is kind of on the
the fringes of Shiar space or at least
one facet of it is but essentially these
brood have come to the realization that
this artifact that was initially taken
by the starjammers and that's arrived
with the New Mutants on earth is
basically a king egg now what this means
and why it matters will become important
as we get through this story but and of
course we'll do a full-on explanation
about the brood you know here in a
little bit because they really are the
universe's most dangerous race right
like they they're it's it's crazy how
dangerous they are what we end up doing
here is basically waking up with Vulcan
now one of the things to keep in mind
here is that initially when Gabriel
Sommers first showed up I really seemed
to first return and during the events of
dawn of X we didn't really know why he
was here right we didn't even really
know why he wasn't the same villain that
he was you know after the events of
deadly Genesis right if you guys recall
the video that we did on x-men deadly
Genesis they're basically detailed the
return of Vulcan Vulcan essentially
being a villain of sorts a kind of Hal
banana on a mission of revenge and then
ultimately after learning the truth you
know he ended up traveling to the Shiar
Empire conquered it and then went to war
with the Inhumans on the Kree and so
because of that you know he's a pretty
significant threat ladies and
omega-level mutant he's wildly powerful
but during the events of dawn and acts
he was suddenly there but he was
presumed or basically seen to have died
you know earlier in in Marvel Comics and
then he was back and seemingly totally
different with no real recollection of
who he was what we know now by virtue of
what Hickman's been showing us is
he was resurrected but he was
resurrected without the memories of what
he had done presumably during the events
of rise and fall the Shiar empire and
all that kind of stuff um it kind of
sucks because that was some really cool
storytelling when it came to Vulcan but
at the same time it also kind of made
sense right because he was a character
that Marvel just never really knew what
to do with right so it kind of gets
Hickman the ability to basically rework
him and make him his own thing the
reason why I gave you that bit of an
explanation is because what Vulcans been
doing is having dreams right having
dreams and nightmares the same dream
every single night and it's always the
same dream that he has or basically he
seems to like conquer the entirety of
the Shiar Empire and then basically the
point where he dies right that kind of
seems to be the same negative dream he
has all the time the issue with this is
that before you can really detail things
any further suddenly the brooder making
their way to earth and that's when
everybody begins to panic that's when
all hell begins to break loose because
the the brood are not one of these races
where they just kind of show up and they
say like we are the brood we're here for
a thing and we demand that you give us
that thing and if you don't then there's
gonna be trouble boy I are I promise you
there's gonna be trouble isn't really
work that way right they just show up
and they're like give us your like
that's basically what they are they just
they just like fittest Deebo people is
really all it is right and so as a
result of that the brood showing up here
they just crash land on earth that's the
one of the reasons why I go kind of
wanted to hold off on this bit of an
explanation because the brood are in no
joke right the brood originally appeared
in Marvel Comics back in uncanny x-men
number 155 right and right off the bat
they were just like this race is savage
like in the most extreme degree they
were so savage and things had gone south
for the x-men so bad that actually
Xavier believed they had died and that's
why he formed the New Mutants team the
crazy thing here is that this is a race
that literally just relies on
overwhelming number that's what they are
they're like the xenomorph from the
Alien franchise right just overwhelming
number and that's kind of what goes on
here so the brooder here looking for
something and you can't reason with them
you can't bargain with them all you can
do is just fight them off and so the
x-men really kind of have to figure out
why their brood are here and then you
know kind of nip that problem in the bud
and they don't really know right they
don't really know why the brooder here
all they really knows the brood are
attacking now the answer comes in the
form of a younger member of the brood
called brew basically brewed without the
deed now he was a character that
originally appeared back in astonishing
x-men vol 3 issue number 14 who was
basically a member of the brood who was
being grown in a lab that was ran by
sort the sentient world off
in response Department in order to
understand the brood physiology now they
also had a brood Queen when the brood
Queen was freed she left a brew behind
because unlike the normal members of the
brood drones brew felt like compassion
and love and things like that and so he
was basically ostracized kind of outed
from the community and then sort of left
behind now eventually he was taken in by
the x-men and he had essentially been a
member of the team ever since he has
intimate knowledge on like the brood
race and its form and his function and
different things like that and he's the
one that basically tells the x-men their
brood are here because of this king egg
and this is this is like they will not
stop and he's right like Bru is right
that's the important thing to understand
the x-men may stop this wave of the
brute the problem with that is the next
wave will come and then after that is
the next wave and after that is the next
wave and the end I mean you gotta
remember this is a race that spans in in
like countless numbers the trillions
right spread all over the entirety of
the universe right they're everywhere
like they're all over the place just
because you don't see them doesn't mean
they're not there they're like termites
right like they could be all over the
place in your wall but until you see one
you never know they're actually there or
unless your walls start falling apart
right like you go to you go to tap part
of your wall and the whole thing
collapses well then you know you got
termites but I mean you know aside from
something like that this is a race that
will constantly show up it is a battle
of attrition and they'll just wear the
x-men down until they get what they want
and then they will leave and so Cyclops
makes the smart move and Cyclops is like
let's bail out of here right so he ends
up grabbing Vulcan he ends up grabbing
basically everybody he can he grabs
havoc he's like let's get out of here
and they end up bolting and basically
you know jumping through one of the
gates heading for Shiar space right one
of the Kirk Owen gates again we talked
about how Cyclops made that request at
the end of the last story that we did on
New Mutants this is the reason why those
little tidbits matter because it all
kind of comes together when it comes to
hickman storytelling and so what you end
up getting here is is basically a member
of the accuser Court now why the secured
course here the accusers of course being
agents of the creek why this accuser is
here will become important as time goes
on but this accuser is basically trying
to get information out of Robert Acosta
and out of Sam Guthrie in order to find
out where this king egg artifact is now
of course isn't you know Robert decosta
kind of goofing around and being a
little silly and so on and so forth but
the fact that this is is being done by
decosta or at least by this accuser does
not go unnoticed by the super guardian
and so because that she basically ends
up chiming in to the to the Shiar empire
specifically to the magistrate's you
know to the gliders agent and basically
says hey look there's an accuser on the
edge of she
space we got to respond that leads to
the She'arim you know she are getting
involved right because they don't take
too kindly to a member of their rate you
know to a member of the accuser Corps
showing up on the doorstep of their of
their empire right it's like not really
your worst enemy but certainly like a
potential threat showing up on your
doorstep and then just kind of you know
loitering around your property right
like I mean if you're if you're like I
am in Kentucky what does get out and
shoot you right I'm ants it's kind of
how it is that's how it is in Kentucky
right you go Laurie ring around the
wrong property notice come out and shoot
you like it's kind of nuts in the the
city of Lexington and in Louisville they
don't do that because you can't fire
within the city limits but nonetheless
you know at this point we kind of end up
jumping to the past and this is where we
sort of get this big explanation on
everything that's going on here right
like everything with the king egg and
all that kind of stuff this is why these
things are so important is because it's
Hickman kind of changing a lot of things
right what we're basically told here is
that 8,000 years ago the Cree ended up
stumbling across the brute and how the
brood procreated was by literally
infecting another biological being right
and basically re materializing them into
the brood and so what they ended up
learning is that you know that the brew
themselves consumed not just the hosts
but all the hosts knowledge right so in
a lot of ways you're like a biological
version of the board from Star Trek you
know where the board basically
assimilate you and all your knowledge
gets you know assimilated into the hive
into the the Borg collective and so they
know everything you know hence the
reason why the Borg were able to
decimate the Federation during the
Battle of Wolf 359 because they knew
everything Picard knew they knew how to
circumvent the the Federation's defense
systems and all that kind of stuff and
so with that being the case there's a
kind of idea here that comes along where
the Kree basically come up with this
idea to weaponize the brood now this is
an important thing to understand is that
you got in these various stories and
different aspects of the brood were kind
of expanded on over the years right in
the sense that you had basically what
was called the great mother which which
essentially the hierarchy follow that
you had an empress who was like the
absolute divine ruler you know the
absolute ruler of all the brood and then
while most brood that existed within the
universe existed by virtue of another
biological being being turned into a
brood the empress also had what were
called her firstborn right her actual
biological children like yeah you know
giving birth to actual brood after the
Empress you had the firstborn and then
you had the Queen's then you had like
smaller versions of Queens and then you
had drones right so but the issue here
is that at the time we never really knew
what the origin of the brood was we just
knew that they were there in Marvel
Comics we just knew that they kind of
there was no real explanation in terms
of where they came from or anything like
that what Jonathan Hickman basically
changed up here is he introduced the
idea of their basically being a kind of
rift in space where the brood are not
native to the main Marvel Universe right
they're not from here instead they're
from a collapsed universe like a
collapsing universe that basically fell
apart and ended up coming here and so
essentially they're they're not from
this universe they're from a different
universe but now they inhabit inside
this universe right and so that's where
things get a little murky that's where
things get a little get a little chaotic
is because they're not really from here
but the Kree look at them nonetheless
and say okay so the entire form and
function of this brood race is they
essentially follow a hive mentality that
you have a singular leader under you
know that that controls the entire hive
and then within that hive you have
various you know Queens and you know who
each one of the Queens leads a faction
different things like that you have all
these these little situations set up but
what we can do is we can weaponize all
of this we can basically create a
singular being that can dominate the
entirety of the brood hive and then
basically either seed or so disarray or
we can use it to our own ends whatever
the case is we can weaponize this whole
thing and that was the basis behind the
creation of the king egg specifically
because of the fact that the supreme
intelligence had looked into the future
at least use a mathematical probability
to determine which of the existing races
across the cosmos and normal comics
would be the most viable threat to the
to the creator on down the line and
determine that it would be the Shiar and
that's true right the Shiar are
technically the most advanced race in
Marvel Comics
they're composed of a bunch of different
races all of which have sworn I failed
you to the Shiar Empire or maybe they
were just straight-up conquered but
whatever the case is like they're
composed of a bunch of different races
but all have their benefits and drama
tried strontium Xand different things
like that who are all essentially
analogs for Superman and so as a result
of this is one of these things where
like all hell can pop off here you know
ah hell can break loose and so kind of
jumping to gladiator and the accuser
this guy is dealt with pretty readily
right you know this morning you're kind
of jumping back to the to the present
day either going after this guy deals
with this accuser pretty quickly right
ends up knocking him out of the ship the
accuser dies in space and then he's
eaten by one of the giant you know space
whales basically that the brooder
controlling to travel from one location
to the next what the brood do they
basically you know kill these things and
then hijack the nervous system and then
take it over right and then just kind of
pilot it it's like controlling a human
as a puppet it's more or less what well
this is equivalent to the issue is that
where the initial X
vacation of the starjammers and uh you
know the the Shiar Imperial Guard and
like the x-men and all these groups here
is like okay you know let's go ahead and
like land on the space station and then
you know leave this you know send the
brood egg to thee to the surface and
then I guess the key get to the surface
and call it a day this station is
destroyed as well leaving them no real
option except to you know basically
crash land on this on this sentient
world and that's where things kind of
pop off is it because over the years you
know what what hickman really hits that
here is across the universe what you
have is you have like all these varying
factions of of the brute right you have
like a faction here and you have a
faction there and you have a faction
back there and you got a faction over
there and they're all led by individual
Queens right each one of the Queens
leads those factions there's no
indication here that there is currently
an empress in existence and so what this
means is that all the brood individual
factions are self-governing there's no
one controlling all of them so factions
will go to war with other factions over
territory or resources or whatever the
case happens to be and so as a result of
that because of this king egg what this
is doing is based it's like the dinner
bell right it's it's bringing in all
these brood from all across the cosmos
right because brood can can smell this
king egg from galaxies away right so
like three or four galaxies away and if
and if one of those galaxies there's a
billion brood then guess what that
billion brood is heading to this planet
that's exactly what's happening here
and so with that going down like brood
are constantly arriving on this world
and while you do have some exceedingly
powerful characters here you've got
Vulcan you've got Cyclops you've got you
know you've got gladiator yet all these
guys well you have some exceedingly
powerful characters here the reality is
no matter how powerful they are they
will start to fall one by one they will
start to fall and they will start to die
and they'll lose against the power of
the brood that's just the way it is
these just overwhelming numbers as
powerful as these guys are they cannot
continually fight against billions of
drones for any real continued amount of
time and so all it's going to take is
for one of them to be infected but then
suddenly it all stops in the in the
middle of nowhere all the birds stop
moving just like that like they stopped
moving they stopped attacking they all
just back off in the ologist stop and so
what you end up having of course are
like these massive you know brood that
are sort of standing around there and
then you've got Bru himself who
basically ate the egg right like he
consumed the and that's really the way
this king egg works and it doesn't
really give birth to a to a brood king
instead it contains a kind of substance
inside of it a kind of syrup and the
individual that consumes it will kind of
become the new brood King more or less
now presumably because of the fact that
the brood basically exists in terms of
their control over you know the the
Queen's control the drones and the
queens in turn are controlled using a
combination of like pheromones and
telepathy what this seems to do is
basically amplify the abilities of an
existing brood right so you know take
that brood and then give them like a
super high level of telepathy and then
like a super advanced version of the
pheromones so they can essentially force
the other members of the brood or
convince the other members of the brood
to do their bidding that's basically
what this is right now you've got a
you've got a brood king which means the
entirety of the brood race the most
dangerous race in all of existence is
currently on the control of a singular
being and that's cool right that's a
super cool idea but the brooder are
super awesome guys I'm really excited to
see what Jonathan Hickman is of doing
with this but if you guys are new here
to come this explain to make sure you
guys are the sub button to become part
of the robb cork if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]